mirrors do not show us a fourth
dimension but they do show us what a
fourth dimension could do to us first
notice that some things are the same as
their Mirror Image but some things are
not these two shapes are similar but
they cannot be rotated to look identical
to be superimposable on each other this
is called being chyal a chyal shape and
its Mirror Image are called anatom
morphs these two shapes are anatom
morphs in two Dimensions no amount of
two-dimensional rotations will ever make
them superimposable to do that I'll need
to smash one of them inside out turn it
into its own mirror image or rotate it
in a third higher Dimension if I place a
sticker here and face that side away
from me notice that the mirror inverts
the object just like a rotation through
a higher Dimension can the side of the
real object that's furthest for me
becomes the side of the virtual object
that's closest to me so what would I
look like if I was rotated around a
plane in a fourth spatial Dimension and
then brought
back I would look like
that